we were on problem 227 when I got a
phone call it was actually from Jonathan
who helps me with the Khan Academy so I
thought it was worth stick he works at
LinkedIn and he wanted to let me know
about all these this news that was
occurring there anyway I I'm getting
distracted let's go back to the let's go
back to the GMAT problems so problem 227
in the coordinate system above which of
the following this equation of line L
and they didn't put this two here in
this three here but from the from the
drawing you kind of can can assume that
this is the point X is equal to three
and this is the point X is equal to two
and then frankly you need that
information to figure out the equation
of this line so first of all what's the
slope of the line right the slope make
sure my tool is right the slope is equal
to change in Y over change in X so when
you go from this point to this point
what's the change in Y it's zero minus
two zero minus two which makes sense cuz
we went down by two and the change in X
is three minus zero whenever you do
slope it's important to remember if I'm
always if I'm if I'm taking this as the
first point on the Y side so zero minus
two I have to do the same on the bottom
three minus zero otherwise it'll get the
negative of the slope anyway this is
equal to minus two thirds and what's the
y-intercept well it's pretty obvious
when X is equal to zero Y is equal to
two so if we so we could say Y of 0 is
equal to 2 so the equation of this line
at least in you know though the MX plus
B form that you learn in school is y is
equal to minus 2/3 the slope times X
plus the y-intercept and that's not one
of the choices they've written it in a
different form they called it the ax
plus B y equals C form so let's see if
we can get it there let's get rid of
this 3 in the denominator so let's
multiply both sides equation by 3
I'll switch colors you get 3y minus 2x
no 3y is equal to sorry minus 2x plus 6
all right I just multiplied everything
by 3 3 y is equal to minus 2x plus 6 now
let's add 2x to both sides and you get 2
X plus 3y is equal to six which is
choice B next problem problem 200 know
what is this problem 200
oh I 228 if a two-digit positive integer
has its digits reversed the resulting
integer 2 differs from the original by
27 so let's say I had a B that's a
two-digit number and I'm going to
subtract ba from it and so the
difference is 27 since I'm assuming a
positive difference right a B has got to
be a bigger number than ba so at least
the way I've written it what do we know
about it well a has to be greater than B
right if a B is greater than B a a has
got to be well right a has got to be
greater than B I was gonna say is could
be greater than or equal to B but if a
was equal to B then this thing right
here would be 0 so if we assume that the
posit that a B minus B a is a positive
27 then that tells us that a is greater
than B or B is less than a so if B is
less than a when we're doing the
subtraction problem we're gonna have to
when we do this part when we do the ones
place if B is less than a we're going to
have to borrow right so if we borrow
this a becomes a minus 1 a minus 1 and
the B becomes B plus 10 now and then
we'd be ready to subtract so what we say
we say we could say that B plus 10 B
plus 10 minus a minus a is equal to 7
which tells us that B minus a is equal
to minus 3 and that's essentially what
they are asking for they want to know by
how much did the two digits differ
well that B minus a is equal to mine
minus 3 that's saying that a minus B is
equal to positive 3 right if you just
multiply both sides by negative 1 or you
could say that the absolute value of B
minus a or
- B or how much they defer is equal to
three right the absolute value of B
minus a is plus three and just to just
make sure that this all works out a that
if we do with the tens place a minus one
a minus one minus B is equal to two
let's add one to both sides you get a
minus B is equal to three so it works
out a and B differ from each other by
exactly three and that's choice a
problem 229 229 the circle okay let me
see if I can draw this so I have one
line I have another line and then I have
a circle it's not it's like right there
so it looks something like that there
it's tangent it has Center C right there
and it says the circle with Center C
shown above is tangent to both axis both
axes if the distance from o to C is
equal to K and do it in different color
so the distance from the origin to see
so they label the origin as oh but that
is equal to K is equal to K what is the
radius of the circle in terms of K let's
think about this so this is right this
is going to deal with triangles and how
can we use the radius and relate it to
this right here
well the the first thing that that might
come to mind is if I just drop a line
straight down from here that's equal to
the radius right that's equal to the
radius because this is a 90-degree angle
right here right it touches that line so
if we could figure out this distance
right here then we could use the
Pythagorean theorem to maybe figure out
what the radius is and luckily enough
this distance is also the radius and if
that's not obvious to you think about it
the distance from here to here is
exactly the same thing as a distance
from here to there right and from here
to here is the radius of the circle so
this is also R so now we can use the
Pythagorean theorem R squared plus R
squared is equal to K squared or two
RS squared is equal to K squared they
wanted the radius in terms of K right so
you get R squared is equal to K squared
over two take the square root of both
sides R is equal to K over the square
root of two do they want us to rational
that's one of the choices sometimes they
want you to get the square root of 2 in
the numerator at least and when I used
to take algebra they used to harp on
that a little bit if anyway this is
choice B next question problem 230 230
and in an electric circuit two resistors
with resistances x and y are connected
in parallel this is reminding me of the
physics videos so they're connected in
parallel and this is resistances x and
resistance y in this case if r is the
combined resistance of these two
resistors then the reciprocal of r is
equal to the sum of the reciprocals of x
and y and that's what they teach you so
if you want to know the combined
resistance of this they tell you and
let's say that that's our they say 1
over the combined resistance is equal to
1 over X plus 1 over Y and if you took
basic circuits this is one of the
fundamental things about parallel
resistances and then they want to know
what is R in terms of x and y are in
terms of x and y so let's let's see if
we can solve for R so 1 over R will be
equal to let's get a common denominator
XY 1 over X is y over X Y 1 over Y is x
over X Y right and then we can take the
reciprocal of both sides so then R over
1 or R is equal to XY over X plus y I
just switched those two around and that
is XY over X plus y that is choice D
problem 231 let me do it in this brown
color 231 Xavier Yvonne and Zelda who
happened to be go by XY and Z at least
in my world each try independently to
solve a problem if their individual
probabilities for success are 1/4 1/2
and 5/8 respectively
what is the probability that Xavier and
Yvonne Xavier and Yvonne but not Zelda
will solve the problem
so Xavier and Yvonne but not Zelda so
that's the case we're looking for so
we're looking for the case so there's a
1/4 probability that Xavier solves it
and then there's a 1/2 probability that
Yvonne does but the probability that
both of them do is 1/4 times 1/2 that's
the problem that they both solve it and
then we want that case and not or and
Zelda can't solve it it's also probably
the Delta doesn't solve it 5/8 is the
probability that she does solve it so
there's a what what's 1 minus this so
there's a 3/8 probability that Zelda
does not solve the problem right and
what does this come out to this is equal
to 3 over 4 times 2 is 8 8 times 8 is 64
which is choice E and I'm out of time
I'll see you in the next video